ein elfjähriger schüler bedroht seine
lehrerin hier in berlin in spanien auf
einer grundschule und droht ihr mit
enthauptung das vorbild soll das
attentat vergangenen monat in frankreich
gewesen sein auf einen lehrer der dort
mohammed-karikaturen gezeigt hat nach
diesem vorfall haben sich weitere lehrer
gemeldet die über morddrohungen zu sagen
haben mit dem getöteten lehrer partie
stehen
es soll sogar eine forderung von einem
erstklässler gegeben habe man fragt sich
natürlich was ist da los wie kann das
sein und genau darum möchte ich nun
sprechen mit burkhard dregger bei mir im
studio
ja sie haben dazu aufgerufen dass die
schulen beim thema islamismus nicht
alleine gelassen werden können jetzt was
genau meint er mit und was soll
passieren
ich habe vor kurzem eine schule in
meinem wahlkreis besucht in der auch
schüler in einem minderjährigen alter
sich auf diese fürchterliche art und
weise geäußert haben und der schulleiter
hat mir sehr eindrücklich geschildert
dass die lehrer damit einfach
überfordert sind weil sie gar keine zeit
haben sich um diese probleme zu kümmern
sie werden allein gelassen wir brauchen
sehr viel mehr psychologen
sozialpädagogen sozialarbeiter an den
schulen die sich um die nicht
pädagogischen arbeiten also die nicht
vermittlung von von lerninhalten kümmern
das müssen die lehrer machen aber der
kontakt zu eltern den auszubauen
insbesondere wenn solche vorkommen des
stattfinden ist es ja so ungeheuer
wichtig dass man nicht nur mit den
schülern arbeitet sondern auch mit den
eltern die ihr offenbar auch dinge
nachplappern wie sie zu hause hören und
das können die lehrer nicht leisten und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass wir das
jetzt als weckruf ernst nehmen und den
schulen diese ressourcen zur verfügung
stellen und hier in berlin ist das
offenbar in ganz besonderer eklatanter
weise nicht der fall also geht es da vor
allem um prävention dass so was gar
nicht erst passiert oder auch um die
betreuung lehrer wenn sie dann von
kindern so angegriffen zumindest mit
worten angegriffen weil es geht um
beides es wir brauchen unterstützung für
die lehrer auch für eltern die hilferufe
absetzen und ich stelle mir das so vor
dass an jeder schule geeignet das
personal dafür vorhanden ist und wenn
solche vorkommnisse stadt finden sich
dann dieses personal gut ausgebildet
zum ziel setzt mit den eltern in kontakt
zu treten und um näher zu untersuchen
wie kommt es zu solchen fürchterlichen
hasserfüllten kommentaren und was können
wir gemeinsam dagegen tun dass zukünftig
zu unterbinden
ich will auch deutlich sagen angesichts
der ständigen rassismus debatte die wir
ja in unserer gesellschaft führen die ja
vielleicht auch notwendig ist dürfen wir
keine hemmungen haben auch das problem
des islamismus in unserer gesellschaft
auch an unseren schulen zu thematisieren
wir müssen einfach in der lage sein das
thema offen zu benennen und auch
stringent anzugehen und da ist jetzt
bisher zu wenig passiert und die schulen
sind der punkt an dem wir die menschen
erreichen können die schüler erreichen
können die eltern wenn wir essen in
schulen nicht schaffen werden wir keine
chance mehr haben außerhalb von polizei
und justiz einzugreifen und das ist mir
zu spät ich finde wir müssen präventiv
tätig werden
wie realistisch sind denn ihre wünsche
oder forderungen jetzt auf noch mehr
geschultes personal es gibt ja sowieso
schon viele menge personal mängel an
vielen schulen kann man das überhaupt
stemmen
das müssen wir stemmen und da müssen die
notwendigen ressourcen zur verfügung
gestellt werden wenn ich mir überlege
was wir uns alles an dingen im haushalt
leisten also auch im landeshaushalt
berlin das sind häufig dinge nice to
have aber nicht wirklich notwendig aber
das hier ist absolute pflichtaufgabe
eines staates prävention gegen
extremismus und gewalt und deswegen darf
uns das nicht zu teuer sein und die
skilehrer führen die momentan einen
heldenhaften arbeit und kampf könnte man
fast sagen aber wir können sie nicht mit
allem allein lassen also der schulleiter
mit dem ich gesprochen habe hat mir auch
erzählt wenn bei uns der wlan abstand
schluss ausfällt dann muss ein lehrer
den reparieren was sollen die lehrer
eigentlich noch alles leisten das ist
gar nicht leistbar das heißt sie
brauchen auf allen ebenen unterstützung
damit sie sich auch um diese wichtigen
fragen kümmern können mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren